Okay,
door A is the show continues, but you have to >> Okay,
here's the ultimatum. Hold on. Here's the >> ability to
ban, mute, and mod people. Or door B show's over. Don't say anything.
You have until the next show. You have until the next show to
figure out your answer. Okay. >> You have until the next
show. It's a >> No, no, no. Don't give your answer. Don't
give your answer. >> You're right. Okay. I'm sorry. I'll
build suspense. [laughter] >> I don't know, man. I just
love >> REMEMBER THAT IT'S STILL remember it's entertainment
here that we're doing. Okay. so much. Hey, we'll build the >> It
does bother me that much. It does bother me that much that people
[music] get banned.
>> So, do you guys remember with Biggest Problem in the
Universe, there's Biggest Problem, then there there's Veto and
Dick, right? And Veto and Dick had a nearly a big breakup last
year. Okay. Um Dick and Veto had a like nearly a breakup last
year. And it's it ended with like Dick. Well, they had two, but
the first one ended with Dick being like, "Veto, I'm actually
giving you half of the show. Veto, you get half of the show now."
Okay.
And it was like a beautiful moment. And then they started trying
to make it work again. And then Dick slowly started pulling away.
And I think Veto called his wife or something looking to talk
to him. And Dick got really about that. Dick was very angry,
right? Dick was very angry. Um,
okay. Okay. So then pickup
then something happened. They kept going for a little bit earlier
this year. I didn't follow very much but basically in the first
weeks of December they started having a fallout. Okay. Veto got
baited from like donations or something into talking about the
Minton Riley situation again. Minton Riley. Riley was the guy
who went to his house went to Veto's house and then Veto was
getting mad at him banning people from the community who were
supporting this guy. And Dick was the whole time was like just
don't engage with it. Don't engage with it. It'll be fine. Don't
ban people. Don't ban donators. Just leave it. It'll be fine.
It'll be fine. It'll be fine.
>> Okay. So, then the next week after that first episode,
the next week.
>> Yeah. All right. >> As long as we're being talking
about it again with each other, >> relitigating it again.
I can already hear that veto might be good. >> Yeah. All
right. >> As long as we're being as long as we're being
open and honest with each other. Tell the audience why I'm not
allowed in your studio.
Um,
every
Oh, I forgot about this too.
Uh, this is another thing. Basically, they started saying, um,
uh, they started saying Dick started saying like he has hearing
problems and he couldn't have veto in at all, right? Like he
couldn't have veto in because he had like hearing problems and
veto yells and then he would have other podcast people over to
his house. He just wouldn't let Veto come to his house at
Yeah. Yeah. Dick like makes it very clear every opportunity he
can that he like actually doesn't like Veto as a person, which
I think is a lie. I think Dick is like some kind of weird hybrid
of aggressive and avoidant where
basically as long as Dick, sorry, as long as Veto is acting a
way Dick doesn't like, Dick will be the biggest dick possible
to him, right? Until Veto changes his behavior, like Dick will
say, "This is what annoys me about you." and and he'll say it
once and then anytime Veto does those things without Dick re
like reiterating what he was about Dick will just be the biggest
[__] on earth, right? Oh, no, no, no. Sorry. Um I'm
talking about Dick and his how he treats Veto. I know Veto loves
Dick. Yeah, I know. I know. Okay, but but Dick will like be the
biggest and he will never tell Veto that it's because you're
doing a thing I don't like again. Right. If he told him once,
he told him a thousand times and he will not say it again. All
right.
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Rawhead Rick, it's very clear that Dick
has just been like very with Veto for a while now, but Veto does
the exact thing that Dick doesn't want, which is Veto is like,
"I want to talk about it. You're hurting my feelings." And Dick
is like, "Be a man, you be a man."
Right. It's crazy
>> because people ask you
on Reddit like major severe hearing problems.
>> Yeah, I do. people. Okay. So, people ask you, "Hey,
why is Veto when is Veto going to be allowed back in studio?"
>> And then you never And you don't say it's because of
my tenitis. >> Well, you didn't let me finish. It's not
100% because of my tenitis. That's how it started. It was uh
that's how >> it was desperate. It was a um it was about
a month or two of just desperation. I got to be able to I got
to try to keep things going in life.
um when your head is just full of uh stabbing pain. Uh I spent
all of it I spent all of it in in uh with earplugs in or at the
doctor's or in the shower.
worried about uh how the rest of my life was going to be uh when
my son was born and [clears throat] >> okay, we're good.
>> If I could even be an effective uh father. Okay, now
this feels real, but also it's so weird.
Oh man, it's so weird to me that this is one of the only times
I've ever seen Dick like be vulnerable and like express his problems.
I don't watch a ton of their show, but I've never ever ever heard
him. You think it's a bit? It might be a bit because like
I've never heard him do this before and it's in this situation
to explain to Veto why he doesn't want him around for a kid without
without being able to hear. Um not just being without being able
to hear but um having hearing be result in severe pain and a
permanent wsece
whenever anyone made a sound. uh whether I was going to be locked
in some kind of nightmare like a Victorian uh uh villain like
Miss Havsham where the whole the whole house had to be quiet
or I just couldn't survive or if I was just going to blow my
brains out which was no longer on the table obviously because
they get a kid and their wife and support them. That was the
first probably two months and that's when all
uh Dick has been progressively cutting veto out of his personal
life. Twitter, the email, then his home for the shows. He has
a kid and a family and a life and doesn't want to deal with Veto's.
He literally doesn't like Veto, but does doesn't want to give
up on the income stream. Yeah. So, but he said this basically
to Veto. I think this came to a head when Veto was trying to
figure out how to get back in the studio and Veto called Dick's
wife when Dick wouldn't answer the phone for him, right? And
Dick was explaining to him, I think he explained to him back
then, this is a couple months ago, like, I don't want to talk
to you. We do a show. you you want to talk to me about the show.
And I think there was also that the show was kind of dragging
at that period in time. And I the feeling I got was like, why
don't you take whatever effort you're trying to put into fixing
our relationship and put it into the show? Why don't you come
to the show with energy? Why, if the show is working, maybe I'd
like you more. Like I felt like it was he was a veto, but he
also Yeah. He was making it clear like the show wasn't working
as well as he liked and make the show better and then we could
talk about being friends or something was how I felt about it
at the time. It does seem like he just has some sort of like
deep antipathy for Veto right now where he's like he does not
want talk about Veto's feelings. Doesn't want to talk doesn't
even want to talk to Veto apparently. Um
yeah and I understand he's made it about his kid.
I think that's a whole other thing too is that Veto Veto is not
lowmaintenance to Dick. It seems like like Veto wants to ask
questions. Veto wants to talk to him. Doesn't bring solutions.
Brings like hey Dick tell me how to do this thing.
I I kind of get it. Like it's like Veto takes time away from
from Dick in a way that Dick doesn't appreciate. And I think
Dick just generally has a life philosophy that that's not a masculine
thing to do. Like Dick's going to accept that from his wife,
but he's not going to accept that from any of his male friends.
His male friends should bring positive value to his life basically
at all times or keep your to yourself. Like that's the arrangement
he wants with his male friends. And Veto's like, "No, I want
to talk about this. We're friends. We should talk about this."
Veto is legally a woman and acts like it. Shut up. That listen,
there's something about Veto that does make him like a a a good
opposite, a good foil for Dick in that like he is sensitive.
He is plugged into like leftwing politics. He he's not dumb,
right? I think this show works really well if Dick's willing
to take on that work, right? But Dick has decided he doesn't
want to do that. So, it seems pretty clear that instead of just
ending the show, he's going to keep collecting the or he was
just going to keep collecting the checks and cashing in for whatever
period of time, you know, the
don't want to be named went down. Um, after that, >> yeah,
all that all that stuff I don't even want to get into >> after
that. I don't know. It's a it's a central nervous system issue.
Um, some people cure it, some people don't, but it is
it might be based on emotion because it's a central nervous system
issue. Um, something is wrong. So, >> so when I'm there,
it triggers you. >> I don't I don't know, Veto, but I will
tell you this and I don't know if I've ever said this anybody
and and um I really I I think you take things differently and
like personally a lot and I don't mean it when I say this. Um,
I'm This is just a coincidence, I'm certain. But the first time
I noticed it was when >> he's he's about to This is what
you say when you're about to explain why. Dude, I don't I can't
explain it. I just straight up hate you, bro. >> Your car
got destroyed and I was driving you home from my house and halfway
through driving you home, I could feel something go really wrong
in my head. And you were telling a story and laughing and for
some reason I the I thought that you were just like screaming
and I was I was wincing and going like what the is wrong with
this guy? Why won't he why is he talking so loud? And I dropped
you off and I could barely say um I could barely say goodbye.
I went home and um the [clears throat] next day it it it faded
a little bit the next day, but then that weekend it came roaring
back
>> So did I create your tonitis? >> I don't I don't
know. I really don't I
What? Did I create your tonitis? I don't know, dude. Veto's like
laughing. I would you
would laugh at this too, dude. What?
I don't know, Veto. There's a chance there's a chance that you
up my whole life. There's a chance that you're going to be top
top, you know, you're going to have the top building of my No,
Veto. First paragraph mention, okay,
it's totally insane to say yes, but it's a central nervous system.
Like it could have been just me. It could be anything. It could
it could have been me. >> You're so annoying. I had a mini
stroke, a micro stroke veto that sent my brain into a tail spin.
That's how annoying >> listening to a movie. It could have
been me playing the piano. It could be me me drinking too much.
It could have been me doing co too much. It could have been me
stressing out about the baby. It could have been me stressing
out about a million other things. It could just be genetic. Nobody
knows. But that is when I that's when I first noticed it. And
um
nothing is worth like prolonging it. Definitely not a podcast,
>> bro. Okay, this is the first time you've said this to
me. If there's me, if me my voice and whatever shrill tone is
causing tonitis, obviously that's >> Well, I don't think
it's causing it, but >> it's not helping.
>> But when people ask you, hey, why is Veto not allowed
in studio? Just
He did sort of grab that thing and go, I can't be cursed, did
he? >> You do this little wink wink. Well, he knows why.
And uh he's never he's never coming back. >> Yeah, that's
true. It changed after that was that was the first two months
out of desperation. But after that, I was like, this is you're
doing way too much weird stuff. I don't want I don't want to
deal with this. This is it's either it's going to be stressful
like this or it's just going to be um this is not something I
want to deal with. I don't like the calling. I already you know
you know that I don't like all the I don't like all the calling.
I don't like this kind of like actoring. Um that's that's the
that's the final reason which so it's partly it's partly Titus
and partly you know >> it's mostly that uh I'm annoying.
>> I don't know man. You're asking me to put like you're
asking me to quantify
>> now Dick is actually being avoidant. I think Dick is
trying to say that I I think Dick truly feels in his heart that
yes it's because you're annoying. that are just highly emotional.
And >> well, I feel like if I'm half the show, we did a
great show in studio and now it's not in studio. Okay,
that's fine. You have tonitis.
>> I don't mind doing a remote show. What I mind is you
constantly kind of doing this wink wink nod nod whenever you're
asked about it and going, "Oh, well, Veto's not in the studio.
He knows why." >> I don't I've never said he knows why.
Never. I say something loud. >> Yeah. and and you've I've
never known exactly what the reason is. >> Well, yeah,
it started with hyper cuses and then, you know, the months the
months right when that hit and the months after it were just
like a nightmare. I thought I don't I don't need to deal with
this. Let's just do a remote show can work. Uh I thought it would
be better. I you know, I didn't know there would be so many issues.
There's a lot of things you can do in a remote show that you
can't do in a in a studio show. I thought it would be >> I
don't have a problem doing a remote show, but like can we coordinate
on it? Can we figure out how to make it work?
Can we like have a open chat room where we just go, "Hey, this
would be good for the show and here's >> the discord. It's
the channel." >> No, I don't want to I don't want a chat
room with other people in it. I don't want to. Okay. I don't
like
an eminently reasonable thing. But I also know from previous
clips from previous segments we've done on the show that Dick
blocked Veto on everything because Veto will bring up personal
stuff like offstream stuff or that what so it's again the Riley
and Mint thing when when Veto was really about people saying
they're going to come to his house. He was complaining to Dick
about it right through different messaging platforms and I think
Dick was just like yeah we don't we don't talk anymore. Literally
you want to talk to me talk to me on the show. So Dick explicitly
doesn't want a a room where it's just the two of them and Veto
is asking for that again. But at the same time, they run a show
that makes like $10,000 a month in revenue. Like they probably
should have some sort of they should have some sort of coordination.
No,
>> it's pretty crazy. >> Be hanging out in [clears throat]
that Discord, which has just turned into the Veto is a piece
of Discord. I don't want to do anything in there. I have >> Well,
you can send it to Doug Trio or Trio Doug. I forget. >> No,
I don't want to do that. I want to just talk. I want to go, hey,
what problems are you doing this week? Remember we used to go,
"Hey, what problems are you doing this week?" >> Yeah.
And it's worked just fine without that. [laughter] >> The
problems are the best parts. You have to admit that the problems
have been fine. >> I guess. I don't know. I mean, yeah.
It's not like a hu Dude.
>> Yeah. Can we just Can we just have a chat room where
we just I'm not going to bother you about >> No, I don't
like I don't like private stuff. I don't like private stuff cuz
you can't What do you mean? Trio Doug will be in there. Have
a seat group of people. We're not doing it in the [__]
Discord. >> Oh, you don't want it in the comms room because
other people can see it. >> Uh yeah, that's fine. Yeah,
make a room for like people who are actually >> No, but
this is No, this this is what this is what up in the group chats
though. Think it's I don't know. I'll think about it. >> I
won't talk about anything at all. I don't Here's the thing. You
seem to think that I really want to talk to you about stuff and
I don't Well, yeah.
>> that's not true. >> I don't want to bother you.
I don't want to be a part of your life. I know that all I do
is annoy you and I. >> Um, so what I'm gathering is that
Veto is probably hella gay and annoying in
maybe. I mean, I think everybody can be like that, especially
like if these two, like I I get the feeling that Dick, this is
like a very small part of his life and for Veto, it's probably
a little bit bigger. And so it builds up more of Veto's life,
right? Dick has got a lot of stuff going on in his private life.
And when you have a a fairly like full private life, you only
give to like work and anything else like what you can like what
what you have available. If you if you don't have a very full
private life, you can obviously give way more to work and usually
people will just fill up their life with their work, right? And
I think Dick Veto is willing to spend like more time but not
like directed meaningful intentful time. And so he'll have like
a like an extraneous thought and he'll put that in a chat with
Dick. I'm guess this is what I'm guessing cuz I've seen people
like this. I've been both of these people at different points
in my like professional career where like I have no time for
any personal [__] at all. And then there's other
sorry for any um like yeah personal between professional relationships
and then other times where like I'm spending all of my time with
on the work stuff. So I've been like both of these people. I
just I feel like I recognize the symptoms. is like Veto doesn't
have a whole lot going on in private. So, he'll he'll be it's
not like he doesn't treat Dick's time like it's uh like it's
gold. And sometimes that's what people want in their professional
relationships. Like literally, if you're if you're using my time
off like it better be you better have a good reason to to put
this message here that I have to go and deal with and clear.
And if you don't, then you're eventually going to lose. >> Don't
want to do that. Okay, but let's put it this way with the Streamyard.
I'm sitting there for 30 minutes trying to rejoin the Streamyard.
You can't see me and I have no way. What am I gonna do? I'm gonna
send you an email. I can't. >> No. Yeah, those are those
are filtered into the into trash.
>> Yeah, I can't.
>> No, you can't send me an email. Those go directly to
SP
you. I was sitting in the back end of Streamyard one time for
20 minutes waiting for you to re add me [laughter] to the show
and I have no way to contact you. >> I don't think a chat
room's going to help with that. >> No, I think >> I
mean that's kind of like an edge case. I don't even I don't even
need I don't even know if I am concerned about that.
Uh what do you call it? Uh
do you have a pro is that your problem? No comms. I think the
problem is that we should re I just hope that Veto doesn't go
down without like a fight cuz
>> like I
my my mental model of like Dick in this moment is
that Dick is like I'm just going to with this guy until he goes
cuz I want this to end. So, I'm just gonna like whatever. If
I this is how I got to do content, I'll burn it down doing doing
content on this. [__] it. I'm gonna be an [__]
to this guy. I'm gonna like abuse him for the rest of this show.
I'm just gonna like [__] with him and I don't care
cuz it's funny and this guy, right? And that's like my mental
model of where he's at. I don't know. Um, Rodmus says he thinks
he's been getting he's been trying to get Veto to quit for a
while. Maybe there was a time where he committed in the other
direction. I thought it was a really good gesture where he gave
Veto, you know, 50% share in the show, right? And it's clearly
gone the other way. >> Let's do the show next week. >> Let's
take a couple weeks off.
We'll come back. Let's think about it. Let's see how we feel.
Maybe we'll do a wrap-up show in January, but let's let's give
it a good Let's give it a thought. >> There's Yeah, I don't
know what's going on, man. I'm not trying to be an, but like
I'm very I don't know. I don't even know how to put it, but I
feel constantly antagonized. I know you think that I'm It's all
in my head. I don't know.
But, uh, I mean, look, it's just maybe it was a great show for
a while. Maybe it's just maybe it's just not a good spend of
of time. Time's very limited. Maybe it's just not a good spend
of time now. The revenue the the Patreon's going down. Support
is falling off a cliff, you know? Maybe it's just I >> That's
That's insane
demotivation for your audience. What?
>> Hold on. Is it just biggest problem in the universe
all one word? No.
>> So, hold on. Patreon.
I'm I'm trying to look it up right now. Patreon BPI TU.
>> Can I see this? Biggest problem in the universe. Ooh,
they have taken a revenue hit. Jesus.
>> Nobody adjusts their Patreon subs, but I don't even
do a show on Patreon. I feel like I've taken less of a percentage
revenue hit than these guys have. Jesus, that sucks. I think
they're at like 10 or 12,000 right for a while.
>> Uh they're they're down. I mean, it's still 6,500 a
month for like I don't think they do like a ton of work. I The
thing about letting it go downhill like this without making changes
is that I think they have a really active community that a lot
of people would for
like their their community like
is like like they are KRD for the show probably for Dick more
than Veto. But there are some people who really like Veto and
Veto is good at his job by the way. I know I know a lot of people
think um that Veto like doesn't do that great a job. He does.
He's pretty good at it. 13,000. So it has. It seems like it's
kind of shifting over to Dick Show. Although I think Dick Show
was around at this before.
Anyway,
look at the six last six months chart. It's going to be brutal,
man. Cuz I remember I the last time I looked at this, I want
to say it was at 10 or 12,000.
Six months.
Haha. [laughter]
Year to date, they almost hit 10K. They almost Oh, sorry. No,
one year. No, they were 11K. So, when we started covering them,
this was
last year. They they this is where they had their first near
breakup and then they got, you know, they were like, "Oh, let's
commit and go and back up to 11K."
see this is their drop off from veto banning people. They bounce
all the way back up to like 11K, 12K, and then they they have
another break up, bounce back up, and then it's just been a slow,
steady decline for the past or like all of 2025.
>> That's kind of rough. I didn't expect
>> I think it's been since they've been doing the remote
show, though.
>> Uh Dick at one point was making like a quarter mill
or more on Patreon alone. His
die hard fans are rabid. Well, hold on. Dick I think still makes
a lot of money cuz I think Dick has other platforms and I think
probably his biggest fans and biggest spenders are probably going
to like the crypto platforms to support Dick, right? Like like
he he was a big he was like a big web 3 guy. I'm guessing a lot
of the donations that Dick gets specifically if he's going to
get donations from like big time oilers, I'm guessing he gets
a lot of that in crypto still cuz he was like a big time that
was the biggest thing when him and Maddox split.
Dick. I think they agreed that Dick would get all the Bitcoin
donations from the show. So, I think Dick got all the Bitcoin
donations and Dick's probably like very a very wealthy guy.
Like a crazy wealthy guy. [laughter] Like Dick's probably got
crazy money to be honest with you. I don't think he needs to
do either of these shows. And I think he said as much. Like I
I literally I don't have to um That was for the Dick Show Patreon
before we went over to crypto. Okay. Oh Jesus. Did the Dick Show
really made that much? That's nuts. Oh, wait. No, you said 250k
a year. Oh, I could see that.
Oh, yeah. No, I could see that cuz it's He still makes like 13K
a month. That's almost That's getting there.
>> Okay. Yeah, I get it. It's weird saying dick all the
time, but >> I don't think it continue. Oh, wait. We're
basically done with this. >> Well, me too, but um
we're not uh we're not anywhere near each other. Uh we're not
anywhere near what each other needs out of uh whatever making
the show is. So sometimes you just got to say, well, you know,
>> I need I need Okay, I need a better understanding of
you told me have good energy. Don't fight with the fans. Fix
your audio.
>> I'm really trying to do all that.
>> Well, so what's the problem
that it seems that like I see comments from you and you go, Vito's
up the show. Veto's ruining everything. Vito is not >> Okay.
Well, I never I never see from you. Hey, you know, Veto's trying.
and video is doing like you just seem to think I'm not doing
anything. What's wrong with the audio?
>> Uh I don't know why your audio took so long to fix.
>> I don't know why I had to get
Look here here. Let me let me let me read you. This is a I'll
just do my problem today if you don't have any. Uh >> I
have problems. This is a this is a problem from the Lok. Okay.
>> Does that name sound familiar to you?
>> Uh does Veto not understand that it's bits like this
that ruin the show? Well, hold on. But Kger, like if you feel
like the show is going down in quality, you're trying to work
on it, it's not working. Like the only option you have is to
talk to the other guy on the show and try to work out the problems,
right? Like that's the that is the only other option
honestly
like is to discuss it on the show. He doesn't want to talk off
the show. You kind of do have to discuss it on the
Um and if you if you don't want like Yeah, I don't know. Yeah,
I I'm sorry. He does. He does have to discuss it on the show.
And Dick knows that. Dick knows that they're going to do these
segments on the show or he would set up a private chat. It is.
Why hasn't he delivered his comic yet? Oh, wait. I think he did
deliver his comic. I think his comic actually got rave reviews.
People actually really thought his comic was great.
I'm not even joking. Like, a lot of people thought his comic
was really good.
When the actual comic people started looking at the comic, it
got really good reviews. Oh, it hasn't printed yet, but the full
copy is out. Okay, I see.
Anyway, so they they basically argue back and forth on whether
or not Veto is actually fixing things, I think. Oh, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. Yes, this >> They argue back and forth
on whether or not Veto is actually fixing anything.
>> I mean, [laughter] here's my I don't I don't know, honestly.
Oh, [__] Honestly, I Why bother? >> I I really
feel like why bother? >> Okay, it could be a why bother
situation. Who cares? Let them say they're going to cancel the
Patreon >> No, I mean, why bother with any of this? >> What?
Doing this show? >> Well, yeah. Why? Why bother with these
>> arguments over why supporters are getting banned and
screenshots and all this quitting the show that the only people
I have banned are people who have said, "I'm not a supporter.
I don't support you. I hate the show and I'm leaving the show."
That's not banning supporters.
The only people who get banned are the people who say specifically
the opposite of being a supporter. And then they go to you and
they go, "Dick, I don't know what happened. I'm a huge supporter.
AND THEN HE GO THEN WHY DID YOU POST THAT saying I hate the [__]
show and I'm pulling they they do this ALL THE TIME DICK. They
go to you and they go I don't know >> I buddy I don't believe
you at all. I don't believe any of this. >> Well I don't
know what to tell you man. You have you seen comments on our
YouTube saying
cancel the Patreon. Everybody cancel the >> No I've pretty
much only gotten >> You know why you haven't seen those?
You know why you haven't seen those? Cuz I [__] deleted
them.
Um, oh man, I don't even know how to think about this because
I do think sometimes get getting rid of like demotivating comments
could be good. Like it's smart not to have those kicking around,
but then there are certain shows
>> where maybe they're fine to leave. I'm not totally sure,
but I don't I don't think that Good job. Um, I pretty much only
get emails about, hey, I supported the show forever and uh uh
now I got banned. you or I'm pulling >> where. Okay, hold
on. Where? >> Probably like I don't know. [sighs and gasps]
I don't know. I'm not going to say maybe once or twice a
>> Enough for it to be annoying. It's It's basically the
only thing I hear. Yeah, once or twice a month. >> All
right, dude. I I feel like there's definitely people who didn't
get banned who like just hate Veto and so they like send ticket
thing just being like, "Look, I supported for a long time. [__]
you." [laughter] I'm going to real quick look at the
Okay. Which says now we have the exit
uh surveys, right?
>> So, this is where because you've decided to leave >> the
uh Patreon, you can say the reason I'm leaving the Patreon.
>> This is like a microcosm of the difference in their
worldview. You're about to VTe is about to try to change Dick's
mind with stats. Dick's mind is made through vi made up through
vibes veto. Okay. And your vibes are bad. He's not going to give
a [__] He's going to be like 35 only 35% of people
leaving said it was because of our relationship or the show getting
worse.
>> That means there's a lot of other stuff go. It's like
Dick's like no is you. It's you >> is because uh veto banned
me. Okay. So that's what they would say. Feedback. >> Wait,
why would they say that?
Because again, you're saying that the reason people are no longer
supporters is they're getting banned. >> No, I'm not saying
I'm saying these people these people that this guy that >> Okay,
so if you got banned, wouldn't you wouldn't you cancel your Patreon
and then in your exit survey say the reason I'm leaving is cuz
I'm banned from sending super chats. I no longer feel like a
person. >> Why would someone do that? Why would Why would
someone fill out a survey? >> Okay. Well, here's why. All
right. Here's the exit surveys from Patreon. All right. Number
11. Dick is turning into a petty bully. It's not funny or fun
to listen to. Number next guy says veto. Next guy says no silly
pants skating routine. Next guy says dick is becoming insufferable.
Next guy says dick. Next guy says it's mostly fighting now. Next
guy says veto is not as funny as he is petty. Next guy says Veto
is a lying awful person. Veto makes the show annoying to listen
to. I'll still listen to the regular episodes, but the show doesn't
have the same energy. Veto shouldn't get any more money until
he refunds me. Uh Veto always talking about nerd [__]
and Reddit tier problems like durr a hot dog is a sandwich. Okay.
So, yeah, there's issues that make people want to leave the show
and me >> What was the point of that exercise? >> Cuz
me banning the one or two people who have posted a comment on
YouTube saying
>> I mean, okay, okay, okay. But
the point of that exercise is to say, hey, we're both making
the show worse. The show is getting worse, but most people aren't
leaving because I banned them. There's nobody saying that I banned
them.
This is like when one party can't accept, the other one wants
to break up. I don't know. I don't know if Dick actually
I don't think Dick wants to end the show. I think Dick would
do this if he found a competent co-host. Or maybe he has to end
the show now because it's 50/50 or something. But like
I don't think I don't think he wants to end the show. I think
he's just really with Vito. >> You should all cancel our
Patreon and go just making what's the point of doing what's the
point of doing the show?
>> Uh I'm sorry. I was I was talking when you when you
made the connection.
>> I I don't think there's anything wrong with what Veto
is doing in terms of banning people. I think that's fine. I don't
think it really affects your bottom line. But what he has to
consider, what he should be considering is, hey, your co-host
really hates when you do that. Your co-host has like a total
like he gets so upset when you do that. Have you thought about
not doing that? Thought about maybe like don't do that. Maybe
that's not a good idea. Maybe that's like really bad idea. Right?
Like that's that's what changes everything into like, oh, this
is a problem for me. Like I don't really care if he bans you
don't ban Patreon commenters. That's crazy. Banning paying contributors.
Um I guess it would depend on what their comments were. Like
if it's about like doxing veto and going to his house, maybe
you ban them.
Um I certainly give people who donate a lot of money like a lot
more leeway. That's me personal. Okay, that's my personal thing.
But um
he was banning people who super chat $50 plus. Yeah, I I just
wouldn't do that cuz I like money. Okay, I'm I'm on the dick
I'm on the dick side there. Okay, listen. If they pay enough
money, don't ban them. If they pay enough money, but leave them
alone. Let them let them let them talk [__] Okay,
if they pay enough >> Yeah, absolutely. >> Say that
part again. >> So, you're saying the reason to not do the
show is because one or two guys got banned and I'm telling you
that they were on posting comments about canceling
>> and you don't believe it? No, I I don't believe it.
Um, >> how many people are banned? >> I don't know.
Three or not? >> Well, you know, it's funny because a >> No,
I'm not. It's one or two. Um, and no one no one no one will
>> I truly I don't think it's that many people. He just
he's gone from like bunch of people, one or two people a month.
Now he's like one or two people.
I think there's like two people have messaged him about getting
banned. And I'm guessing one of them he knows is like a big time
like pays a lot to the show or something is like a longtime viewer
who has oiled the show like for a long period of time and Dick
probably like was like oh that's the final straw. Like if there's
a guy Dick's been doing this forever. Dick's been doing this
for like a decade, right? If there's a guy he's known for a decade
who's one of the early supporters of him who like gives a bunch
of money to the show and that guy gets banned for one random
comment to veto, I could see that setting off a bunch of >> them.
You know, they don't care about one guy, they only want their
show, they're going to be they're going to be for even bringing
this up. Um, but I think there's I think there's still better
things that we could be doing with our time than having these
arguments over
who said to ban the like like moderation, like comment moderation.
Like, it's not this isn't something anybody wants to be doing
or listening to. Uh, >> I can get rid of all our current
moderators cuz maybe one of them is [__] around.
I mean, >> maybe. I don't know. I I don't know. I I think
maybe we should just take some time off and think about it and
[sighs] figure out what to do. I don't as much as I don't want
people who supported the show to get [__] over, I
also don't want active supporters and listeners to get [__]
over, but you know, time is precious, man. Uh spending it in
this spending it in this toxic like arguments over content comment
moderation is not comedy. Um sometimes it's just best to to walk
away. Wait, what? If that's the case, what are you if that's
the case, we should do a final show like in January and just
put put it to bed. You know what I mean? Think about it. Do you
Do you have a problem that you want to bring in and we'll think
about it? We'll take a couple weeks off and come back. I'll take
a couple weeks off. >> I don't want
and we'll think about it. It's just like it's such a waste of
time. No one >> Why is Why is it a waste of time >> to
argue about content moderation? It's
It really doesn't matter up. I'm not the ONE WHO BROUGHT IT UP.
What do you mean?
uh, oh, I couldn't disagree more, Moody Morgan. I couldn't disagree
more. And I think Veto's showed this in multiple places. Veto
thinks he should be the star on the show, thinks he should be
treated like talent, and he just isn't. Veto is the sidekick
trying to act like the main character. Learn your place. Oh,
you're so wrong. Veto is actually I've watched how flexible Veto
is going to like different shows and being funny, being like
an absolute value add to a bunch of different shows. He was great
on Kicker Keep. I heard his PKA episode he just did was amazing,
right? He's able to go and fit in a bunch of different places.
He's very flexible. I There's a reason Dick wanted to do the
show with him. Okay, there's a reason they've made this work
for so long. I know it's up now, but Veto is very good at this.
Veto is very good at also being the butt of jokes and not taking
it personally for a long time. Okay, maybe not as much in the
past year and a half, but I I totally disagree when people are
like, "Oh, Veto is not talent." No, Veto is good. No, but every
I understand that Veto is not good for the exact like audience
that
Dick has had for like a decade. They don't like that guy, right?
But Veto is good. And I if you can't see it, you're kind of in
my opinion.
Like he makes for a very entertaining show.
Uh it's not even that it's a mismatch. It's literally just a
personal like literally this dynamic served them for years. This
dynamic made the show good for years. It's just that it got into
their personal lives in a way that Dick like is just irritated
by and it seems to be like shutting it down, right? He seems
to be shutting it down. But I I do think this dynamic like that
Beto's the sensitive and Dick's like this this like hard ass
who's going to constantly like, you know, beat him to death on
the show. I think that dynamic served them really well. They
had a very entertaining show. They made a really good run of
it. I I just think it it went into their personal lives in a
way that couldn't be recovered. It seems like Okay. Not not declaring
it dead yet. We got to wait for that. >> Well, yeah. I
didn't think it would turn into an argument. I thought it would
be an explanation or something. Not about
>> made up things about who said who may have said what,
right, >> bro? You You asked me why did this guy get banned.
I told you the only reason I would ever I ban people from the
comments. And I never b anyone for super
>> that's my problem.
>> Oh man, >> you got one. We can read super chats
and then call it a night. I mean, >> no, I'll do my problems.
All of this could be so much simpler. Here's what I'm going to
say.
I'm excited. I'm excited for this next >> Okay. What is
it? >> Did you hear about a portion of Interstate 5 that
cuts through San Diego experiencing an
>> Okay, that's it for this show. Now, for after this show,
they take Christmas off. Okay. They take Christmas off. They
take the next week off. I think it's two shows off. Two shows.
Two shows. About two shows. Three shows. No, two shows. Two and
a half shows. Three shows. Three shows off. Two shows off. They
take two shows off.
Week show. Week off. week off show. Okay. And that the next show
after
>> ends quite unceremoniously. All right. >> Here's
my announcement. Uh
>> here's my announcement. Not good. >> Do I got
to be here for this?
>> Yeah. This is how I look at it, Sean. I think people
people don't like Veto because Dick doesn't like Veto and they
like Dick and they're there to watch Dick's show and they don't
really care about Veto. They just want somebody to be there with
him, right? And
but Veto is good and people just don't get it. If they if they've
never seen any of his other stuff, him appearing with other people,
he's quite
>> Yeah, you can be here for this. You should be here.
>> I mean, I can be >> Yeah, I know. You have to
be here for this. Uh I mean, I can't control what you do, but
you do. The show is It's making less money,
>> you know. >> I can fix that. >> And it's
a No, it's not >> Oh, god. [laughter] >> It's not
a thing to for you to fix. It's it's uh most of it is me saying
we have to go virtual, which is which has not been uh we >> say
virtual and it can still work. That can be done.
>> Oh
no. Oh, that's painful. Oh boy. >> There's one thing I
was thinking about it. I saw you were doing a call-in show and
I was like, "Oh, did you watch the call-in show?" >> I
didn't watch the call show. Those are usually fun though. I don't
I'm all right. I'm good. That's People say it. I'm sure people
like it. That's what I thought. People Oh, good. That's nice.
People like it. Veto has a phone on those.
But [gasps] then I got another email that said Veto banned me.
Dude, I'm sorry. Dick has to understand that he needs like all
the proof in the world for those emails cuz as soon as I if I'm
like dude, if I don't like Veto, I'm just going to send Dick
an email saying Veto banned me. Like I hope he got proof. >> Who?
Who says I banned them? >> I'm [__] Is it okay?
Hold on. Hold on. No, no, no, no, no, no. I know who it is. You're
talking about in the Discord.
No, actually, [laughter] >> CUZ I SAW YOU IN I saw >> Oh,
no. DICK. VETO. VETO. NO. DON'T CONFESS to banning talk to a
guy. And the guy goes, "I got banned." That guy did not get banned.
>> Who was it? >> What's his name? He He He showed
up before the live stream started.
Oh, good. Looks like Veto's going to up the show again. Nobody
super chat. And so I muted him for 24 hours. That's not a ban.
He was muted. >> Let me find him. Let me find him. >> A
mute is not emails. >> Well, yeah. I muted a guy. >> Why?
All right. All right. All right. All right. Hold on. Hold on.
>> Because we were doing the call-in show. It's only for
people who like the >> Dude, this is rough watching Peter
just try to This is now like a breakup. I didn't think it was
quite a breakup before, but this is now a breakup where like
Dick's like, "We need to talk. I think some things are going
badly." And Vito's like, "I can fix it. I CAN CHANGE. I CAN CHANGE."
It's like, dude, I don't
I don't know, man. [laughter] You're just in there to go, "Oh,
the [__] show. It's going to suck." Okay, you're
muted for 24 hours. It's not a big deal. You can show up on the
next episode. >> It is a big deal. It is absent. Being
muted for 24 hours is a big deal. >> I can chat. I can
It's It's a big deal with everything combined. Look, here's my
here. Look, I'm going to I'm going to explain it very simply.
I'm going to explain to you where I'm coming from. If I'm doing
a show by myself, I should be allowed to mute people. >> Do
it on your own channel, then. If you want total If you want total
control, do it on your own channel. The problem is The problem
is this is not a new thing. I was thinking about it and I >> I
came to the realization that >> we did a great call-in
show. >> I'm sure it was. >> And part of the reason
calling show is because there wasn't one guy in there going the
whole show. Duke folks, >> I'm sure muted for 24 hours.
>> His [laughter] name was I'll read his email. So tonight
on the on the solo Christmas show, I made
>> once ny comment and banhammer. I wasn't the only one.
I cannot chat. I cannot comment. I cannot participate. I have
no incentive TO BE SUBSCRIBED. I CAN'T
Like I
I do feel bad for Veto because I do think like
this could have probably been communicated through, but I also
think like Veto's Veto is almost guilty of some similar levels
of like communication failure in that said multiple times like
I don't want this to happen. I don't want people to get banned
who like make snarky comments. Don't ban everybody who does it.
Like please don't.
And it's a 50-50 show.
the [__] are you doing banning people? Like I again
and Dick said it. You want to do that on your own channel? Go
ahead. I like banning people. I think it's funny to ban people.
I usually unban people, right? That's my channel. That's how
that's how it works here. Okay. I ban you, then I unban you.
It's a whole meme. Okay.
But Dick doesn't like it. And Veto won't stop doing it. It's
not hard to dude. It's not hard to understand that Dick's eventually
gonna get super and leave. >> Veto is the business. I don't
know why he says it's a business. one bruised feeling at a time.
Fire that fool and get literally anyone else with some charisma
and a bit of wit because Veto has neither and everything about
him seems scummy and fraudulent. I would appreciate if you could
shame him into unbanning people that say hurt words that are
not that hurty. He is A GINORMOUS. LOOK AT ALL THIS all this
[__] email. I got muted. I got muted during Veto's
live show that dick wasn't even there for. And what do you do?
He immediately runs to you and starts crying. HE'S CORRECT. I
WENT, DUDE, I PUT ON A great call-in show. Everybody had a GREAT
TIME. >> SPOILED BY THIS. SPOILED BY ONE guy not being
able to go into the chat and go, "Well, actually, this sucks.
Actually, this is the worst." >> THAT DOESN'T MATTER. THAT
DOESN'T >> THAT'S WHAT FANS ARE. THAT'S WHAT FANS ARE.
NO, NO. LET ME EXPLAIN THINGS to you. That is what makes a show.
You need all of these people when we have when we're when we
have a thousand
>> Honestly,
Veto should debate those people. That's that's what I've come
to in all of this is I'm like, "Okay, if you're going to complain,
come to stream and and I'm just going to cut heads off of people
verbally on the stream. Okay, that's what we're going to do.
I do think cutting heads off is important, though. You really
got to do it a lot.
Like, it's very important. Veto should have just done content
with it, man. When we're streaming to like 600 people, every
one of these people is important. Every single one. AND YOU DO
not have the authority to ban them for both of us. THIS IS WHAT
I'M SAYING. >> IT'S NOT A BAN, it's a mute. We have never
said anything about muting people. He's only in the chat because
he wants to spend the 2-hour entirety of the call-in showing
on you. >> I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU GUYS are laughing at this.
THIS IS ACTUALLY SUCKS. It's actually not good.
>> Those people turn into fans. >> Okay, they do.
>> Like I I can agree with Dick a little bit. Okay,
>> I can agree with Dick a little bit. If somebody you
dial into your show and they're you and you start them back and
go, "Don't be a get on the get in the cord. Hop on the VC right
now. come and make your complaints here, loser. Right? And then
you just like if you just brutally ruin them for like 10 minutes,
they'll become a fan. They'll be like, "Oh, that's that was fun."
Yeah. No, the muting thing, dude. They mean Dick is like, I don't
like that this guy was muted and but he says banan ban and veto
is trying to rules lawyer on it. Not good.
>> Trust me. Trust me, they do. And when I started, when
I started, and by the way, Veto's funny enough to make that work.
Veto could make that work. Podcasting, everybody hated me. Everybody.
Everybody. But then over two years or whatever, they're like,
you know what? I still hate this guy, but I either I love listening
to him. I can't stop listening to him. Or you know what? I like
this guy now. That's what the job is one way. Okay. And the way
you're all this all of this started. All of this started. All
of these problems started the day you started going nuts banning
people. >> I never went nuts banning people, first of all.
>> Okay. Go ahead. explain it. >> There was one show
where everybody was saying, "Don't super chat." Nobody super
chat and I should have muted them. I I hit ban intending to unban
them later. Okay. So, you want me All right. So, then you just
say to me, "Hey, Veto, never ban or mute anybody." >> I'm
saying this I'm saying this to you now. I want to make the show
good again. I want the money to go up and I want all of the drama
to stay to stuff that's like silly silly and stuff and not about
money stuff. But when I get emails from people that were banned,
I'm like, uh, this is like what I this IS LIKE MY LIFE. This
is what I I need these people's money. THIS IS A REALLY BAD THIS
is a really bad thing that's happening. And it's not only the
money though. It's also when you ban people, they hate you. Like
Well, again, I didn't ban that. >> They actually really
do. It's kind of funny. you dude. Um, [laughter]
dude, uh, Weed Lau in the Discord has been like a Patreon supporter
for a while and I banned him for a joke for like 30 seconds
and
no, actually I banned him for longer, but it was a joke. It was
a joke the whole time and he unsubed from the Patreon and then
I unbanned him within like I think 30 minutes and he resubbed
again. I was just like Jesus that was like a joke. That was just
a meme, bro. It's just a meme. I I muted him, which I think is
funny. >> He took it to It's not funny. It's not >> It's
obviously FUNNY. HE WAS IN DISCORD GOING, "I CAN'T BELIEVE he's
still in Discord posting about it." Okay. >> Oh, I will
say if you ever I have one hard rule, though. If you ever mock
people for engaging, for clipping, for engaging, for liking tweets,
for shilling tweets, for shilling any of my content or my friends
content, you ever mock people for doing that, holy, you're getting
perma out of the community instantly. I don't give a who you
are. Just leave. If you don't want this whole thing to work,
you can go. Okay? Off. Don't talk to the people who actually
care about the content, want it to be good, just yourself. Okay?
>> Whatever. If the Here's my offer. Here's my Hold on.
Don't Don't do me a favor. Do me a favor and don't say anything
about what I'm saying now. Save it. Save it. Save it. Don't say
anything. >> I won't say anything. If if if
you got two options, okay, door A is the show continues, but
you have to >> Okay, here's the ultimatum. Hold on. Here's
the >> ability to ban, mute, and mod people or door B
shows over. Don't say anything. You have until the next show.
You have until THE NEXT SHOW TO figure out your answer.
>> You have until the next show. THERE'S NO GIVE YOUR ANSWER.
Don't give your >> You're right. Okay. I'm sorry. All right,
I'll build suspense. >> I don't know, man. I just LOVE
>> REMEMBER THAT STILL. REMEMBER, IT'S entertainment [laughter]
here that we're doing. Okay. >> So much. Hey, we'll build
this suspense. >> It does bother me that much. It does
bother me that much that people get banned. It does. >> Muted.
Muted. >> Whatever. Well, it's all the same thing now,
unfortunately. It's all become the same thing. >> It's
not. It's a 24-hour thing, and it automatically wears off, which
is why he's in the Discord. We went, "Oh, I guess I'm not banned."
>> Look at all this automatically. >> You see all
the words that he's writing here? This is ALL THIS IS HOW YOU
WORK. >> This is all mad. >> I'M SORRY. HE DOESN'T
KNOW. IT'S a 24-hour thing. So, you just during one show you
don't get to go actually this is the worst show ever and Veto
like sucks and we can just have a fun calling show. But you're
right. That's not the nature of the game.
I will think really deeply about
and then we'll have it the next show we do. You got to give your
answer. But it's got I'm serious. It's got to be relinquish relinquish
mod admin. So this band stuff is done. The band stuff is done
because we GOT TO LOOK LOOK. WE GOT TO MOVE. It's got to be 10
steps forward. It's got to be two steps forward, no steps back.
Right now, we're doing two steps forward and then I get a ban
email. Two steps forward and then there's no you get everybody.
Look, I get Can I be clear? I get emails about you all the time.
I don't bring them to your attention. >> All I care about
is the banning thing. All I care about I don't care if you argue
with people. I don't care what you're saying. I don't care if
I don't >> I feel like Veto should say, "Okay, I'll give
up mod. I but we have like a open line of communication again
until I complain about mod or like something personal to you
cuz like I'm not doing the whole thing where I don't have mod.
I don't have any control. I'm totally and I also can't even talk
to the co-host. That's like I'm that dude that's stupid. That
would be crazy. >> I'm just saying. Okay. Don't make it
seem like nothing. Like I also get people going, "Oh, I'm quitting
the show cuz Dick did this and I don't bother you with it cuz
I don't I go I don't care >> but all I care about is the
band. >> But if it bo Okay, all right. >> Because
because it's our money. You don't have the right to say I got
it. No money. No money for dick either. Okay.
>> For three grand a month. Um
I mean it's not about three grand a month. It's like for your
dignity to not be like the totally partner of the show, right?
Like that's that's what it's about is it's for your dignity
to be like I don't just show up here and I'm like the the sideshow
for everybody. That's to me that's what it is. >> I banned
maybe one person on my show ever. I feel I felt bad about the
time like I can't do that. I thought about doing I said I can't
do that to Sean. >> And again, if you go into Discord,
you got that same guy who emailed you going, "Well, I guess I'm
not banned, but whatever." Okay, he's not banned, >> but
I got it. We'll we'll think about >> Think about it. >> Right
now, I'm leaning towards demolishing the show. >> You know,
THAT'S YOUR CHOICE. I JUST BANNING PEOPLE SO MUCH. It's my favorite
THING. AND I
KNOW THAT you do that. So much fun. [laughter] >> IT'S
NOT WHEN I GO. I HAVEN'T EVEN STARTED THE call-in show. It's
like an hour before it starts and I got A GUY GOING, "HEY GUYS,
I do
I get where I get where Veto is coming
I'm just like, "Dude, if you're just here to ruin the vibe, I
I will give anybody the pass if you're going to hop in the Discord.
If you want to whine in the Discord and make content for me while
we yell at each other, that's fine. But
man, there are some people there's just like a vibe killers.
I don't know.
I'm I'm starting to listen to Dick. I'm like, maybe I shouldn't
ban people as much. Maybe
maybe banning multiple people a stream is not a strategy for
growth. Perhaps. No, Yogi can stay banned from that loser. Um,
but perhaps banning I don't even care about the Discord. If you
care about being banned in the Discord, you're not a fan of the
stream. I really don't care. Honestly, if you if the Discord
like sincerely makes makes or breaks the community for you, I
don't actually care. You could you could just go. You're like
not really that into the content. You're into something else.
You know what I'm saying? Anyway, >> this show's going
to be so bad. It's going TO SUCK SO MUCH.
>> I I unbanned Ozel, but listen,
it's one of those things where like you have you literally like
you have certain people who you give power to and you need to
let them make some decisions, okay? Or else they're not going
to there's going to be no benefit to them giving them power.
Okay? I I unbanned
Unfortunately, Ozel picked an enemy that he couldn't win against
and so he's
No, hold on. >> Wait, what did this guy Did this guy just
say he didn't do anything? This Ozel guy just said I didn't do
anything. Yes, Ozel.
I know how to annoy people just like you. Do you think I'm not
an annoying too? I am. I know exactly how to annoy people. I
walk back I said this back like two weeks ago. I got unbanned
from spicy chat like two weeks ago. Okay, I'd been like banned
for a long time
and I got unbanned and I immediately silo added me and was like,
"I'm watching you." And I said, "Shut up, Black." Knowing full
well that I would get banned for that, okay?
And then I got and then I got timed out. And I was like, "Okay,
that's that's what it is." You did the same thing, Ozel. You
did the exact same thing. You showed up and you decided to be
annoying.
You know, you did. Don't pretend you didn't do it. You showed
up to try to annoy the person who you know didn't like him or
who you know didn't like you and you succeeded.
You won. You got the thing that you wanted.
I said Merry Christmas.
That person doesn't like you.
You were adding them cuz you were like, "Hey, I'm
That's what you were doing. You're just pretending. Oh, I just
said, "Merry Christmas. I'm just a nice guy." No. No, that's
not what you were doing. Why are you even pretending that that's
what you're doing? You know that's not what you're doing. Is
being annoying against the rules? Yeah, it is. Uh yeah, also
Ozel, you did say you wanted to kill them multiple times and
then tried to sneak through the fact that you were trying to
kill them or saying you you wanted to kill them repeatedly. There's
also that part. Anyway, we continue muted. But you know what?
I got it. >> Yeah, being an annoying freak is a crime in
that Discord. Not prosecuted enough, by the way, for my taste.
Okay, being an annoying freak is a crime and they don't enforce
that law enough.
If it's really >> you know, Primus, you know, that's not
good band Primus. >> No, I don't listen to Boom. >> You
don't listen to that [__] Uh their their catchphrase
is Primise sucks because when they started playing, everyone
would just say Primus sucks. I hated them so much. But then they've
won them over. >> Yeah, but here's the thing is I'm not
going to win that guy over ever. >> Yeah, but you are cuz
you're funny. All they care about is if you're funny or not.
That's really it. It is. It's none
your dude. They could make you could do content out of this.
You could do content out of this. And it's like,
you come on. And it's like, okay, if you want to if you want
to criticize me, you come on, you do the call-in show. If I had
this size of an audience, okay, we're going to do the call-in
show. You come on. If when I ask you questions about your personal
life, you can be vague enough not to get doxed, but like if you
want to come in and me, I'm going to ask you what your job is.
You be honest when you answer. I'm going to ask you about like
your interests and I'm going to get to know you so I can you
accurately. Okay? That's what you got to do. You got to be willing
to give me some stuff so that I can actually go in on you for
being a loser. The loser that you are. Okay.
I don't know. There's like a lot of ways you can make this work,
man. >> You're out of your mind. You're out of your mind.
All that all that matters is that you're doing a show and that
you're funny or not. People don't care about it. You could rip
someone and they wouldn't care. >> So true.
So true.
Okay. So then on the next show, Veto gives his answer
his answer to the vault ultimatum. Okay. We're basically we're
basically done here. There's more stuff here. I don't know if
they I don't know if it's like really required to get all the
way to the end. Hold on. Let's speed up. There's two minutes
left. [laughter] >> We'll see if there's anything else.
Oh, hello.
Hello. Hello, Myra. Thank you for the gifted sub. I also forgot.
Thank you for five gifted five big gifties from Myra. Thank you
so much. I also forgot to thank Bobby McGee for the gifted sub.
Thank you so much, Bobby McGee. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
All right. Big problem 25 guys on the show. And don't sign up
for the Patreon or maybe do I don't know at Patreon. Okay, there
we go. That's That's the end of the show. All right. And then
our next
>> here. Whoops. Whoops.
>> Oh, I opened this up multiple times. Very cool. Very
awesome. Very awesome. Okay. Here we go. This is Veto's answer.
The ultimate. >> It is the moment of truth, everyone. The
ultimatum of 2026.
Will the show continue?
Will Veto give up his
mod powers
or will the show
be ended? This is the question you've all been waiting a week
>> And now
you get the answer on. >> Dude, what is the energy, man?
>> This January of 8th,
whenever you want, Veto, you get to pick door number one or door
number two. or do you want some pick thinking? >> You just
end the drum roll
>> uh just email me. I'm not really sure exactly what it
is you want. So, just give me send me a message and uh tell me
what you're asking for. All right, show's over, [laughter]
[sighs and gasps] It's been fun. Uh okay, that's definitely a
meme, right? That's got to be a meme. There's no way that that's
Listen, the fact that this blew up into a whole thing does make
me believe that it's not a meme.
Yet at the same time, >> um, thank you.
>> I I fully believe Dick would do that. I fully believe
Dick would go, I'm taking a month off of the show at minimum
be just because you did that. Just because
you around like this instead of like just because of that, we're
done. We're done for at least like I I don't believe it's truly
over. I do believe they're going to take some time off though.
Unless one of them goes nuclear in the aftermath, okay, which
I do think Veto has a propensity to overreact.
Ah, Veto, don't do something crazy. >> Thank you for supporting
the show, all of you.
Um,
it was a good show for a while,
but
there you have it. [gasps and sighs] Goodbye everybody. I'll
see you tomorrow. Royce is coming in the studio. Uh, it'll be
fun. >> Rawhead Rick, what I just said was something of
a, you know, it's a little bit of showmanship. I'm not giving
it away that Veto does go live after this. Okay, cuz he does
go live after this and it sure didn't seem to be a joke. Veto
did not think it was a joke. Okay, it does not appear
for all intents. It does not appear to be a joke. That is perhaps
the worst ending of a podcast ever. What the [__]
That's like some Soprano [__] they just did. Okay,
so
Veto goes live on The Biggest Problem 20 episode 2015 after stream.
Same outfit, right? I do believe so. >> Not going on a
pickle dio
>> Yep. Same same outfit, same hat, same shirt. So,
>> Is this public? >> Is really worse than the first
time the podcast has ended? Oh, yeah. It's way worse than that
time. Yes. Welcome PFIA FRO. Yes, way worse than the first time
it ended. As in it actually ended this time. It wasn't Dick just
going like, "I got all the money in THE WORLD. YOU THINK I NEED
THIS, VETO? YOU THINK I NEED THIS?" It wasn't that. It was Vic
going, "The show's over. You I'm out.
>> Can I [__] this up?" >> And then Veto
tries goes live on the channel after that >> stream settings.
>> We'll see how that goes. >> Welcome. Welcome to
the after show. Uh, I just wanted to be uh clear is uh yeah,
I'll give up uh whatever Dick's asking for. I just don't know
what that means. So, I just need him to like
send me an email saying exactly what he's asking
Uh like do you mean you want me to delete my like accounts?
I think
again it's just like
I can't tell if Vito is doing his own form of trolling here or
what because it's pretty clear that Dick wants like clear concise
communication
that going to the show when he's trying to do a whole bit and
then just say yes and yes and I have some questions I would be
like dude it could just be yeah I'm willing to give stuff up
like you don't need more clarification than that right yeah I'm
willing to give stuff up is playing into it I think he's playing
into it man >> but I guess I wasn't clear with that. >> Uh,
so yeah, I'll do it. I don't I don't That's fine, but like I
need you to tell me what to do. Like I don't I don't know. You
can't just say give up your ban permissions. What does that mean?
Like do I do I not have access to the YouTube anymore? Do I not
have access to the the Patreon? I'm saying you have to send me
a message telling me what the hell that means. No, it didn't
tell me. I need like the details. How do I What does giving up
mod permissions mean?
Anyway, yeah, I don't care. I'll do it. But I don't know what
it means. And apparently he thought that meant that I'm not gonna
do it. No, I'll do it. >> I don't think I don't think I
don't think Dick misunderstood. I don't think Dick thought that.
I think what Dick thought was,
oh, here's this guy like literally literally adding more out
of out of scope work again. Here here comes Veto adding more
work. Literally just agree. Just agree, man. Just agree.
Guess what? Guess what's gonna happen after he agrees? Dick's
gonna go and say, "Okay, I need to take this stuff away from
you." Right?
>> To actually message me and say, "Okay, here's here's
exactly what I need you to do." There you go.
Anyway, guys, you want to play some video games or >> I
don't know what he means. >> So, he asked to send me an
email telling me what he means.
>> Here's what accounts have to be deleted. See if my video
games work. So, uh, I don't know why he's saying that. Get the
show's over. I didn't say I didn't say no. I said, "Yeah, send
me a message. Tell me what you mean."
You got to be specific. I'm not gonna have The point is I don't
want to have a big conversation about it. I don't want to have
a big debate about it. Just Yeah. Okay. Tell me what you need.
Let's
I think isn't it kind of like definitionally that you do want
to have a conversation about it if you're just asking for
get to our video capture device?
It does say something about Dick and Veto. No, no, no, no, no.
It's the opposite. MSFT. Okay. Microsoft Excel spreadsheets.
It's the opposite. Actually, it says something about them and
Dick specifically that this could not be a troll. Like that Dick
would get that annoyed at like a conditional response from Veto
that he'd just go it. I don't care about the money anymore. I
I literally don't give a cuz it's not just the money that they're
making now. It's a brand that's existed for a long time. And
realistically, if they could find a way to reconcile, the brand
would make make a lot of money again. People would come back
to the show. They are funny. They do a good show together, right?
They could make this work.
Oh, hold on. We go again.
Wait, where's my Elgato?
And oh, wait. Does this work still? Video games.
Video games. Nothing works anymore. Hey, you guys want to see
a cool game? Let's play a cool game.
Anyway, if Dick wants to come on and uh Yeah, I'll open it up
for calls. Let's take some calls. How would I do that? >> Oh,
he's gonna take some calls. >> Whatever you want, I'll
do it. I did not have time to figure that out because I have
no
I'm not ending the show. If Dick thinks I'm ending the show,
he's incorrect.
Uh I'm happy to give up whatever mod powers are,
but uh again, I just need him to tell me what he wants. Just
tell me. I made the binary choice. I'm telling you right now.
All right. If I got fired, fine. But I'm telling you, yeah, I'll
do it. Message and we can do that. I don't think this is the
way to handle all of this. Take some final callers or end the
show. All right. Yeah. How do I take callers? How do I do that?
>> That's enough to end the show. Of discussion is Veto
Gizwaldi.
And my camera is working. There it is. I meant to say, should
I try to figure out Streamyard? It seems like Streamyard's got
some better stuff for managing. I can't imagine that there's
still not anything good on Discord for managing things like Streamyard.
Like there isn't a Discord plugin to do like some Streamyard
like stuff with Discord.
It just feels like it's such a core
I know Streamyard is for boomers. I know. But there are elements
of Streamyard that are good that are like better. There are some
elements that are better
than just Discord.
Like specifically how it handles cameras shifting around. Hey,
>> specifically how it handles camera shift >> But
uh I guess I didn't get it out. >> People jump in, jump
out, >> but yeah, I meant to say yes, that's fine. Just
you know, you always make mistakes in life. You always make mistakes
in life. Liquid Heavy Machine, are you there? And if the show's
over
I'm just gonna try to get some calls because all day I all day
I was like, I'm gonna tell if you can call in using the uh link
in the chat. Tell me how I [__] up. Here it is. Cuz
my my exit I got the exit wrong. I had all that time to uh to
say the right thing and I said the wrong thing. Oh, here's some
people. Hey, Kaden.
>> What made you decide to do that? >> Cuz all day
I all day I was like, I'm going to tell him uh Yeah, just email
me and we can figure it out cuz I don't know exactly what he
means, but I should I should have said, "Yeah, that's fine."
I meant to say, "Yeah, that's fine." >> You didn't know
what he meant by either take away your mod privileges or end
the >> Well, I mean, it's fine to give him my Well, I don't
know what take away my mod privileges means. Does that mean I
don't have access to the YouTube anymore? >> It means you're
not a mod anymore. >> Yeah, but how do you do that? I need
like the instructions on how to like what what how do I do that?
>> You you don't need to know how to do it to agree to
it. That's
that's like so
Oh man,
Veto
up in a way that I I hate to say cuz I like Veto. I don't want
to like on Veto, okay?
But I managed people like doing the whole software thing for
quite a while and I' I'd straight up like not want somebody like
this on my team. I've gotten people like this fired
Um, and it's the it's the behavior of
you come to me,
you you could solve this problem if you just had the will to
ask yourself a question about it before you come to me. Like,
if you come to me and I ask a very obvious question to you that
you haven't run down, you're taking my time up. Okay? When you
haven't when you haven't run down, it's like, well, how do I
even do this on YouTube? It's like, one, you could Google that
[__] Two, why does it matter? All we're asking about
is you agreeing. Do you think it matters how you do it when I
asked you to agree to it? Right. Three, there's Are you a bully
to your co-workers? No. No. But I do. When I've had a couple
people who break through this like syndrome, okay, where it's
like it's like the kind of person where I give them a task, they're
like expected to do something, right? And they finish the thing
and then they stand there. They like they literally just AFK,
right? Like it's it's literally you just AFK. Oh sh Oh, what?
Oh, Twitch. Twitch is gone. We got We got banned on Twitch, I
think. Oh, no. I didn't get banned on Twitch. Wait, I got Did
I not get banned on Twitch? Wait, what the [__] happened?
I Hold on. Wait, is my Twitch banned? Cuz I'm still streaming
to Twitch, so it's weird. Uh, temporarily unavailable. Yeah,
I did get a community guideline strike. Okay,
I'm still outputting to Twitch, but I'll shut it off. Okay. Okay.
I don't know why we got banned on Twitch, but hey, it is what
it is, man. Uh, for what? I think it's for Ogre Boy linking me
the dead bodies. We'll see. Is Dick banned there? No. No, Dick's
not banned. I've watched Dick on on Twitch before. Um, I'll shut
monthly streaming
I'm pretty sure it's the ogre boy tweet with the Iranian bodies
or whatever. I'm pretty sure that's what got me.
I wish you guys would pay attention when you go to link.
Hold on. Let me see. I'll see what it is and then we'll continue
on with this with Veto's Collins real quick.
Oh, that actually might something up for me. Uh, we'll see.
How do I find my Hello my Twitch? My Twitch. Hello. Oh, well,
we'll keep watching this. I'll try to figure out what it is.
Give me a second. Well, I mean, what does that mean? Just delete
myself from the YouTube channel. Okay. Most important this year.
What's up, >> Yeah. Uh, I think it does mean delete yourself
from the YouTube channel. >> Okay. Well, then say delete
yourself from the YouTube channel. Let's say give up mod permissions.
I mean, I think the first thing to do is say, "Yes, I will give
up mod permissions." I did figure it out after the fact, but
>> Oh.
Oh, it could have been me talking about how I mod people. Like,
you need heads on spikes, you need to cut heads off, but it's
that's all metaphorical.
So, that's kind of annoying. Like, I'm I'm literally talking
about banning people. Hold on. Let me I'll see trying to find
it. >> You understand the whole beef was like you wanted
to talk to him privately anyway. Also, I haven't seen the episode.
Well, I don't want to talk to him privately, but he's got to
tell me, "Hey, when when I say give up your mod permissions,
I mean, I don't want you to have uh Okay, let's put it this way.
Like, I got to handle right now. I hand all the money on the
Patreon or whatever." Like, do you not want me to be involved
with the Patreon at all? Like, I don't know. I don't know what
he's asking for. >> Well, how do you feel? >> So,
what I meant to What I meant to >> Wait, what?
Hateful conduct. Posting a combination of words or emotes praising
or supporting a hate crime.
Did I praise or support a hate crime? I literally don't I don't
even know what that could be. What the heck? What the I'm very
confused about that one week. They didn't give a time stamp,
I don't think. But there might be a time stamp or something on
the appeals page. I'll have to log in and check. >> Say,
"Look, man, I want to ban anybody. I don't need the permissions
to ban anybody, but do you want me to delete all my accounts?"
What does that mean? >> How do you feel about the show
being over now that it is over? You know, you can always look
back on what you could have done differently. But what are you
going to do going forward? >> I mean, if the show's over
because I didn't uh I didn't say it in the most eloquent way,
like y'all give him mod permissions. Okay. I mean, that's it.
>> Stylo thing. Shut up, Black.
No way.
No way. No shot. No shot. Come on. I do I do think it's the heads
on spikes thing. I It's got to be right. >> The show's
over. So, what are you gonna DO NOW? >> UH I MEAN, I'LL
DO a different show >> Do I do another show? >> What
you What type of show you going to >> I don't know. I'll
figure something out. >> All right. >> I mean, I'd
rather just keep doing this show. I don't understand why the
show has to end. >> That's not an option anymore. You did
give up mod privileges. So, you've got >> No, I AM. WELL,
I MEAN, I'M HAPPY TO GIVE UP MOD PRIVILEGES. I just didn't say
it in the most eloquent way. >> I don't understand. >> I
timed out Nemo at the beginning of the show. Oh, I unttimed him
about now. I feel bad. >> I should have said, Here's what
I should have said. I should say, yes, I'll give a mod privileges.
Send me an email. But I'll admit, I got a little frustrated with
the drum roll and all the buildup. I was like, I just want to
get out of
>> Just going to be you repeating the same thing 20 times
in a row. >> I'm just explaining what happened. I should
have been more I should have been more like I got a little frustrated.
>> Should have, could have, would, you >> Well, you
know, I'm an imperfect person and uh I'm not going to lose, you
know, I'm not going to lose sleep over it. A lot of this has
been Veto makes a mistake and uh doesn't get it. Veto says something
he doesn't say in the most eloquent way and then we rake him.
>> Do these people want Veto to go? I don't know who's
calling in to be honest. >> But the reason I got live is
I ended the stream and I immediately going, "Oh, see I got to
end the show cuz you won't go mod." I'm going, "No, that's not
what I was saying. I was just saying, look, send me a message.
Tell me what you want." I don't know how that got interpreted
as I'm not going to go mod because that's not what I said. >> He
asked you a yes or no question at the end. So wasn't yes. >> Well,
you're right. I should have said I should have said yes. I should
[clears throat] have said yes. >> But what's next? You
got to go back into graphic design. You You better stay. >> I
don't know. No. I mean, yeah, I'll probably lose all my money.
I'll be poor. I mean, >> are boys coming back? I don't
I don't see how people think this is a show ending to be honest
with you. But we'll see. You know making money. The talent is
Waldy. I mean you're going to bounce back. I just want to know
how >> uh you know it's going to be tough. >> Oh
this guy's this guy's he's not on Veto's team. >> It's
not It would be tough for a normal man but someone as talented
as you. You've got >> this guy this guy's bee.
FIGURE IT OUT. This guy's mocking you. He's saying you're not
talented. Veto. I mean, that's the other thing somebody brings
up. I already said I would do it on the bonus episode. Like,
I already said I would do it. So, I didn't know. >> He
gave you He gave you a week to think about it. And I feel like
>> And what I came up with, what I came up with was I said,
"Look, I don't know exactly what you mean. Give up mod privileges.
The way to handle this, and I don't want to handle it on the
show. I don't want to have a debate about it." If he comes, he
came to me and he said, "You're not allowed to see the financials
for the show anymore. You're removed from the Patreon." Be like,
"Well, that's kind of weird." I don't know exactly what he's
talking about. So, I was just like, "I just want to handle this
privately. I don't think it should be part of the show." That's
what I was trying to say. >> Do you think he knew that
you weren't going to give a yes? >> What's that? >> Do
you think he knew that you weren't going to like give the right
answer? because I feel like, you know, >> I think he was
trying I think he was trying to deliberately frustrate me and
uh he succeeded in that and I did get flustered. I should have
just given a firm yes. That's fine. Yeah. >> But he successfully
flustered me with the drum roll and the buildup and the you know
what I was like I just want to get out of here. I don't like
how we're handling this. >> See you about me personally.
I built different like I've got zed to me. So if I was in that
situation I would be flustered. I'd be like you know what I accept
it. I trust this partnership and you and the show more than any
of these minor details about financials. I want to keep going.
But you know you >> that would have been better. That would
have been better. That would have been better speech. >> That
would have been how I had I should have rehearsed. Yeah. You're
not as talented as the guys at most important.show. Shout out
to Most. >> No, I handled I handled it wrong. I got flustered
in the end. I take an L. I take an L. >> What are you gonna
do with your Thursday nights now that they're free? >> I
don't know.
>> Is getting tricky. He's giving I like Yeah. Uh it seems
like he had every intention of like giving it up. Maybe maybe
he's kind of hinting a little bit that maybe he leaned into that
to just be annoying. >> I guess we'll have to hope that
Dick Masterson would understand. I got a little flustered in
the honestly. Yeah, he probably won't. I think he's looking I
think he wants to end the show any It's very possible he wants
to end the show anyway and any amount of frustration. I think
he just needs to understand that I'm equally frustrated when
I'm going I don't even know if the show's going on and I see
this guy tweeting like hey I got a big announcement. I'm like
what's the big announcement that I don't have a job and if so
just you know tell me. >> Well the big announcement that
you had one chance to save your job and you didn't take it. So
>> yeah I [__] it up. All right. Here's Liquid
Heavy Machine. Hey what's up man? Hey man. What's up? How's it
going? >> I agree. I think that he uh kind of did bait
you into that. I think he's I've been watching I'm like old I'm
40 so I've been watching Dick Masterson since like the Dr. Phil
stuff way back in the day and I think he just hasn't want to
do the show with you for months. >> I just can't I don't
want to I didn't want to make it into like this power thing,
man, where it's like are you give up your mod privileges and
it's like a big thing. I'm like, let's just handle it privately.
I really don't want to >> definitely bailed on the conversation
at the end there. >> Yeah. I'm just like I was just frustrated
and I should have I should have said hey [clears throat] what
I had to say was listen man I want to make this show something
you want to be a part of. >> Audience right there in that
moment and I'm sure most people aren't going to watch this live
stream. They'll just watch the episode. It looked like you didn't
give him the answer he wanted immediately and he kicked you.
>> Yeah. No, I was just like I really want to just make
this show something that's fun that I don't have a bunch of anxiety
every week >> and I'm coming into it and you know >> I'm
like okay let's just figure this out and move past it >> and
it's like the nature of the show was to it was designed around
building anxiety for you. You know >> the anxiety has been
okay the anxiety has been driving me nuts. Yeah.
>> I've been going I've been going completely nuts. Let's
put it that way. Is that every week I come in and I go is something
going to happen on the show where I'm a bad guy and the audience
is telling me what a bad guy I am what a piece of [__]
I am. went I don't want to make this whatever this issue is into
another public veto's a bad guy we won one over on him we took
away his mod privileges look I don't want to ban anybody I was
like can we just please >> handle this whatever it is send
me an email we'll handle it privately that's what I was trying
to communicate I don't think we can do that anymore and that's
the problem is I'm like well >> all right I'm I'm like
less interested in the veto cope now a little bit um yeah
U-Haul decides to pick up so it's driving over towards these
protesters right a little bit loud
and then he picks up speed going through the actual crowd dude
Dude,
this is in LA, by the way. It's in It's a Iranian protest, but
it's in LA. Dude,
Is there like a news story on this yet? Hold on.
Let me see if I can find a news story on this cuz I'm trying
to find some news story on this guy going through this crowd.
See if there's like anything about Oh, yeah. Right here. Live
updates.
Uh, Iran warns against potential US involvement as protesters
divide crackdown.
Let's see here.
Videos from Iran show anguished relatives of dead funerals and
protests.
Where's the truck? Where's the truck at? U-Haul drives through
crowd of anti-Iranian government protesters in Los Angeles. So,
a moving truck drove through a crowd of anti-Iranian government
protesters during a large demonstration in Los Angeles's Westwood
neighborhood.
Les the LA Fire Department responded to a report of an auto versus
pedestrian in the area. The agency said two patients were evaluated
at the scene but declined treatment. Resources are delayed. Okay,
so did this not hit anybody? I don't know. I can't find like
the real the full video. They're pro-shaw. Wait, the protesters
are pro Shaw or Dude, I don't who's legitimately
Is there anybody? Are the
Dude, is there's legitimate on the ground support for the Shaw?
In what way? Like that was just like okay I in my head I'm just
sitting here like dude there's no way. Literally as a no shaw
sign. Okay.
Diasporoids. All right.
Every Iranian in the US
really
I just don't I truly don't believe that there's like a ton of
on the ground support for the Shaw. It just doesn't seem likely
to me. I'm sorry. I'm gonna watch this. I don't know how bad
this is going to get. I'm gonna watch it.
Dude, there's a guy on the ceiling.
>> What the [__] This
>> this doesn't look as bad as I thought. When I thought
when I heard plowed through, I thought it was a bunch of people
like getting run over. That doesn't look like people were getting
run over there. That looks like people are getting pretty far
out of the way pretty quickly. I know. A bunch of Pro Shaw radians.
Why?
I can understand like wanting the regime back like that regime
that time, but I don't understand like legitimate
legitimate like feelalty to a monarch. Just seems odd to me.
Like a displaced monarch that's been gone for 50 years. Seems
odd. Just feels odd. I don't know.
Yeah, maybe not 50 years. Sorry. The R on Sha.
The Sha of Iran was the former monarch of Iran.
Do you not think Cud's force is possible? I don't even know what
that question is supposed to mean.
Um, looks like the cops got the driver out in the middle of that
crowd. Yeah, they did. That's the first video I saw. Hold on.
Looking for the first video I saw real quick. I just wanted a
video of him like actually pulling through. Hold on. We got this
right here as well. Multiple people injured, several several
nearly killed after U-Haul truck emlazed with anti- monarchist
anti-regime signs drives through a pro monarchist anti-regime
march on Veterans Avenue in Los Angeles hosted by Iranian diaspora
in California. H
Oh, you think like this guy would be a part of their intel system
like doing an attack here? I don't think so.
I don't see how that's possible given this guy didn't even try
to run people
The Sha's son is seen as a democratic figure. People think he
could transition the country to democracy like the king of Spain
did when fascism ended there.
Maybe. Why is it only women screaming? I have no idea. I don't
know, man. Maybe this whole thing seems it it
feels like this was a demonstration. I don't know. The guy like
Hold on. Maybe this is going to be Hold on. Oh god. It's a cure.
Who just linked me? The GV just linked me a Kersh post. Are we
gonna Are we going to watch Kir? We're going to listen to Kir
right now. Okay.
Oh god. Don't have my opinion. There's been an unfortunate incident
in LA with a U-Haul plowing into a crowd of anti-committing protesters.
The man should never have been able to get near the crowd with
a U-Haul, but some info about the situation seems to be. Signage
on the truck is both anti both
uh is anti both the Shaw and the current
Is this his actual position or is this camouflaged to have gotten
into the protest to an attack? No. Sha, no regime, no mulla.
Mullah is a religious leader, so possibly referring to the current
leader and not a king like Pavi.
Timeline appears to be anti-committi protester
protesters try to rip the signs off the vehicle and are bashing
the windows and eventually his passenger side window is broken.
Guy in the U-Haul then stutter stops forward into the crowd,
eventually accelerating further, then stuttering again, then
full stopping down the road. There's a man surfing on top of
the U-Haul in the third video. Below, I have posted another video
showing the man on top of the U-Haul trying to take the pro the
posters off of the side. So, he's likely part of the anti-committee
protesters. U-haul truck driver is taken into custody by police.
We'll watch that video in just a second. Is this is this a case
of the police not having the street sufficiently blocked off?
So, a guy was able to get a U-Haul in there. He should not have
been able to drive a U-Haul this close to a massive protest crowd.
There are a lot of people saying this is a terrorist attack.
I don't think this is a terrorist attack, dude. Wait, what part
of this seems like a terrorist attack to people? It seems almost
explicitly like not a terrorist attack.
Like this guy didn't I I don't think this guy wanted to kill
people or else why was he stopping until he had his car beaten
to the point the windows were broken, right? Like if this timeline's
correct, it seems like he drove up. He was not trying to get
like
>> Yeah, he's like stopped here. That's not a terrorist
attack, right?
What's the definition of a terrorist attack? Um, trying to inspire
terror.
Was he trying to inspire terror with his
That guy's got that guy's definitely got like a ring on to do
that with, right? You can get like a ring that does that. That's
going to that's meant to like shatter glass like that.
That was like no weight behind that punch. Any ring. Okay. Okay.
So, like he's stopped there. He's not doing anything. And then
he gets his window shattered
as these people like climbing on top of his car. I I don't see
how this could possibly be considered a terrorist attack. Yeah,
I know. I know. That's what Jonathan Ross did. Uh, okay.
Very strange. What's this one? So, he stutters. He stutter stops.
Stutter stops. But the road opens up a little bit trying to pull
through. I mean, obviously the guy's a shouldn't have been pulling
his truck in here at all, right? You think he was just scared?
No, I don't think he was like scared until they broke his It's
possible. Listen, it's possible he's thinking something along
the lines of, "Do you see what Will from TX said?" Nope, I did
not. It's possible he's thinking something along the lines of,
"I'm going to go here. I'm going to do things to irritate these
people until they start like beating on my truck. Then I'm going
to plow through people or something, right?" Could be something
like that. That seems fairly complex. The driver was part of
a terrorist organization, MEK. It's obviously a terrorist attack.
This is a terrorist attack. So he he he drove up for a terrorist
attack and instead of like lining people up and just speeding
through people, the drivers are Marxist. It is far-left violence.
Look up M the MEK. Everything on the truck was MK stuff. There
are psycho leftist cult who used to be on the terrorist list
until they lobbyed to get it off. Get off of it. Wow. Um I just
don't understand how it's clearly a terrorist. Do you want to
Will, do you want to explain to me how it's clearly a terrorist
attack? Like if you're a terrorist, why wouldn't you just go
drive through these people?
If you wanted to kill people, why wouldn't you go? Like if you
were trying to do like literally just political violence, why
wouldn't you just drive through people? It just seems like I
I gave a reason for why you might not like it seems like he's
trying not to kill people explicitly while also getting out of
there. So maybe I I don't understand
I don't understand how it's clearly a terrorist attack right
now to be honest with you. Terrorists are bad driver. No, he
was there to protest and he was stupid. It's like a it's like
a written house thing, right? But I it doesn't seem clear to
me that he's like um he did end up driving through. Yeah. But
would you say he had reason to be concerned for his safety? Like
obviously put himself in that position. So maybe he doesn't get
off if he like actually hurt somebody here. But I'd say like
it didn't seem like if he's a terrorist, if he had terrorist
motives, I don't see why he wouldn't just drive through. Like
he explicitly stutter stops right off the bat when he's leaving.
Like when he goes to first take off here, he goes and then he
stops. He literally slams his brakes so he doesn't run somebody
over.
That seems really bizarre to me if it's just a pure terrorist
attack,
right? Oh, what's going on? Some [__] popping off
here. Why is this being carried by everybody as truck slams into
protesters? I haven't seen a protester yet. The CNN article says
two people were offered medical attention and denied it. Refused
it. I I'm I'm super
at what people are saying right now.
plowing into a crowd of anti-committee protesters. I have seen
no evidence of this. Man, you're so cringe. You think this is
how normies will interpret this footage? Uh, okay. When I look
at a CNN article, I'm not looking. So, this is a little better.
Drives through,
bro. If you're like a news if you're a news Twitter.
Okay, this guy should join the stream.
Come on and whine in person or you're just getting banned when
you It's Discord or banned. Tier five chud sub. Go ahead. discord.gg/jc.
Hop in the discord if you want to appeal your ban if you want
to come on the stream and actually talk some. Good luck. Okay.
Resources
delayed making patient contact to the size of the crowd. Okay.
>> The U-Haul.
>> Dude, I I do wonder how that guy on top of the U-Haul
got down. That guy seemed kind of if that U-Haul is trying to
speed away.
>> That U-Haul seems pretty bad. I I just can't argue with
those people in chat the whole time. I need them to call in.
If they're going to be mad, if they're going to get mad about
stuff, they got to be calling in, man. Can't just deal with the
people getting mad about
Annoying annoying people. Okay.
Don't do it. I'm just looking through a couple messages here.
>> I think that previous tweet, the one with the four videos,
is the one we
Holy [__] [__]
Holy [__]
>> How do you How do you as a person control like your
animal instinct here to chase this guy?
>> How do you do that? Cuz like if you chase him and actually
try to like pull him out of his vehicle, you're probably going
to make things worse. Like you probably are going to push him
to drive through people at that point, right?
Yeah. I don't think the driver has any idea he's up there. Let's
see one more video. Oh, he made it. He made it. Because this
is where they pull him over. This is the final video right here
is he's getting like pulled out by the cops, I think. Oh, this
guy this guy barely lives and he's like, "Let me cut my ankle
tendons trying to stomp this window out." That's not what I'm
saying. That's not what I'm saying. Come on, man. That's not
it. Get the [__] out of
>> Hold on. You read this one yet?
>> Okay. There's videos of them pulling him out and him
getting like beaten here. Hold on.
He gets hit by somebody. The cops are pulling him out. I Somebody
from over here like hits this guy at some point.
dude. The cops are just holding him. People coming in taking
swings. Cops aren't I didn't see the cops detain the guy who
took a swing.
That's crazy,
>> bro. What the
booted this dude in the head. Look like a cop did it? I don't
think so. You can see the cop trying to fight with this guy.
The cops are like holding this guy back. They're trying to hold
this guy back. There's a random dude in a black shirt comes forward
and
doesn't throw a great hit.
He's arrested. We got him. He's arrested.
Interesting.
Okay. All right. All right. All right. Um, is there is there
anything else we're missing here? I'm looking at I got linked
to timeline as well. Just a second. Dude, I'm
I wish I was more awake right now. I'm like I'm like napping.
If I was more awake, we would be flying through these links.
I'm just looking for the timeline. I think uh Moody Morgan sent
me a timeline here. Timeline tweet. One second. Finding it. Finding
it. Here it is.
We need the timeline right here. Take another look. A driver
allegedly drove a U-Haul truck into a crowd during an anti-Iranian
regime protest in Westwood Hollywood or sorry, Westwood, Los
Angeles. And videos show that the truck truck bears the message
no sha no regime. USA don't repeat 1953. Nomula.
Authorities were still sorting out injuries and motive in initial
reporting with local outlets described the situation as developing.
ABC7 reported the chaos that chaos erupted near the federal building
in Westwood after a driver allegedly plowed a U-Haul into the
crowd during the planned protest. After which law enforcement
pulled a man from the vehicle and appeared to take him to custody.
ABC7 also reported LAPD said no ambulances were called to the
protest while acknowledging it was unclear if any injuries were
reported at the time. CBS Los Angeles reported at least two people
were injured with Los Angeles Fire Department paramedics treating
two people at the scene who declined transport to a hospital.
The science message is Yeah, we got the message was confirmed
versus unconfirmed. Confirmed by local reporting. The incident
occurred at the anti-Arabian protest unclear in early reports.
The driver's identity and motive and definitive injury totals.
Different outlets reported different initial death details. Not
deaths, details. Okay, dude. I don't think I don't think anybody
died here. And they're like there's a bunch of people posting
that it's um that like this this truck plowed through the crowd.
>> Very weird.
>> I don't think he was on their side. No, no, no, no,
no. I think it was well understood that this is a proshot protest
apparently. I think he was trying to make a point and didn't
realize people would get that violent that quickly. Okay. All
right. this Iranian disinfo ecosystem.
I mean, if they're anything like the Russians, yeah, they just
want to make things like confusing, right? As confusing as possible.
All right. We're back to Okay, that's I thought there'd be more
here.
>> I don't I genuinely
>> don't see how people think there's a terrorist attack.
And I think I think that's really obvious. It's weird that somebody
came in here who just joined the channel and was like, "You're
a useful idiot, dude." Like, bro, I don't even know. How can
I be a useful idiot? I have no idea who's responsible for any
of this yet.
>> How can you be a useful idiot before you have any information?
>> Very confusing.
>> Yeah, I think No, I think we got all the we we saw the
links. We watched
>> but it's uh >> Yeah, I just don't think there's
anything else here.
>> You show this angle. Hold on. I I missed one angle that
I watched right off the bat. I need to get caffeine. So, also,
I'm going to let this play for a second. Oh, I do want to watch
this. No. Oh, this guy's definitely not a cop.
Throws one punch. I guess you can't detain people right now.
Oh. Oh, that guy got hit in the head already with a flag. Dude,
they're throwing Dude, THEY'RE THROWING THEIR FLAGS LIKE
just like the Persians.
Oh my god. So cool. Jesus, dude.
Okay,
>> dude. The flag is also me. What flag? Wait, was there
a flag in the first Oh, hold on. Hold on. There a flag in the
first video.
>> Not this one. Hold on. We had a We had a first video
here. It was from
>> Oh, was it any of these? No, it was this guy. This guy.
The first first one from
The I I had timeline here with four flags. Give me a second or
four videos. Here we go. I think it was this. I think it was
this one.
The four. Nope. God damn it, dude. I'm so out of it with my with
my links. Show me anybody got the link with the flag that shows
the flag of these people. I'm looking for the first one. The
early reporting one
like where he drive where it's just him stopped there. Oh, this
one right here. Thank you.
>> No shot. No regime, no mull.
>> What flag, Will from TX? This that's that's the flag
you're talking about. It's on the other angle. What? Wait, what
angle?
[screaming]
Hold on. What's the QR code? One second. What is that? What is
that QR code right there? Can I Can I snap that? Oh, it's too
too angled. It's too fuzzy. Don't do it. You're now in the MEK.
Uhoh.
Uh-oh. Will from TX. Where's Where's our flag? Not on this one.
unlikely to be from this one. Where's this flag? This MEK flag.
You going to end up on a list? Yeah, but I'm in Canada. What
can they do? They literally can't even do anything, man. Yeah,
Will, I want to know what you're talking about. Where is the
flag? I don't see it on any of the videos we've seen, and I haven't
gone to get my drink yet. So, now I'm annoyed. Now I'm annoyed.
Okay, two seconds of Veto Cope with this guy. Okay. While I get
some caffeine so I don't handle something like this privately.
I I don't know, man. I don't want everything to be a spectacle.
It's been the weirdest watching experience because you guys seem
to click on the problems and on the banter and then there'll
be some super chat or something and Dick will just jump down
your throat for a 45minute conversation.
>> Yeah. Uh and I've I've tried to find ways to be like
uh you know like I'm trying to figure out how to negotiate around
that. And part of that was me in my head going to stop publicizing
all this like hey man if you got a problem I banned a guy you
know you got an issue with it. Let's not turn into a big unfunny
fight on the show. And that was kind of my mentality tonight
is I'm like hey if there's a problem let's just handle it privately.
Let's figure it out that way. Again, I should have said it more.
I was prepared to say it more eloquently, but I wasn't expecting
a big Oh, here's the drum roll. I thought thought Chud went pretty
hard at you off the jump this morning. I thought it was funny
that I was I thought I played it well. I I was like laughing
like, "Dude, do you want me to I if you're going to do this,
I can pretend to be Pisco for you. You want me to role play Pisco
for you?" Like he was annoyed. He wanted to go hard. And
I I obliged eventually. I started like yelling too
cuz I I felt like he wasn't he wasn't hearing me at all what
I was saying. He was like ready to fight with other people. I
was like, "Oh, I I like some subtle point on self-defense." I
was like, "Oh, I don't know how he claims self-defense when um
seems like he forgot who you are." I don't think that it was
I don't know. It was pretty funny though.
Chud forgot to socialize after months of solitude. Forgot how
to.
Um I talked to Chud this morning on his stream. I was like basically
the funny thing is I think we basically had the same opinion
and he he thought I I think he thought he just assumed was it
not a bit jarring for you? Um I well I think what happened cuz
it took me a second to like explain. I think he was like oh JC
and Queen are friends he's going to be like you know some of
the Queen people who probably been you know hitting him pretty
hard in his discord. It sounded like he's kind of irritated by
people like hating on his take. And I just had like some some
like subtle point about how I don't think you claim self-defense
when you like actually like you're you're worried about other
people's safety when you put people in more danger by like through
your actions. It seems like a weird argument. And he's like legally
no just legally you could do this. And I'm like, well, okay.
I don't have really a huge disagreement for that.
It I thought it was fun to be honest. I don't mind that. I just
I matched energy. I I came up slowly and then I yelled at him
at the end about some stuff. I still think, by the way, I still
think the um what do you call it?
I think a simple flowchart
actually totally knocks down his point about how like like when
I'm saying you should get out of the way of the vehicle. He's
saying that's the only part I was like dude I'm pretty sure you're
totally wrong on this and
I'm pretty sure you're entirely wrong on this was I was saying
okay you you should have a priority of getting out of the way
of the vehicle of not dying first and then you can pull your
gun and you should be trained that way. and he's like, "Yeah,
but then people will just like drive their vehicles weirdly to
um" And it's like, "Dude, I I'm pretty sure I don't want to call
you a total like on your stream, but I'm pretty sure you can't
create a situ." I was asking him, I was like, "What what situation
is that?" Like, could you describe the situation that you could
create where somebody is now going to like somebody who wasn't
going to run you over is now going to run you over cuz you're
not allowed to pull your gun immediately when you're in front
of a vehicle. He could say he's focusing purely on the legal
side, but then he slipped into what should be as well. And I
pointed that out. I was just I was gentle because I figured,
yeah, this guy's uh had people going at him. Dirty is he I turned.
By the way,
Chud's chat
Chud's chat usually hates me. Very shockingly, a whole bunch
of people flipped to my side during that argument. They're like,
"Oh, they I think I think I won a lot of people over in that
chat. in that argument. I think Izzy was the only person who
thought that argument didn't go well for me.
It was very fun. I Dude, I've never Chud's chat has never been
nicer to me than during that conversation. It was very weird.
It was on kick. I couldn't believe it.
But I also He was like trying to yell and get going and I'm like
I like dude I you when he was yelling and getting going it's
like on points I agree with. I'm like yeah I agree on the legal
part of this show the conversation. I'm not going through the
conversation uh like to to
post game it. It was funny. He also he got really mad because
I was I was talking about his logs as if they were serious.
He got upset about that. It was pretty
Got a Somebody's got a time stamp. People link in the time stamp
in the chat. Just go find it. You'll find it. He's like looking
at some on stream. I didn't go look at his links that he sent
me though.
Um Oh, I should tell Straight Aid whenever. I don't know how
much more veto cope we want to watch. Probably not that much
more. I think I started I started really winning over his chat
though when I um I started arguing that the cop was like being
a total because obviously this fat suburban white woman was with
a dog in her back seat is not looking to run people over. And
he's like, "Oh, I don't know that. You just want to racially
profile?" I'm like, "Yeah, I want to racially profile. This fat
old white woman is not looking to run people down. She's not
looking to murder cops in the streets, obviously." And yeah,
you should have a bias in that direction because a tattooed black
person if it's a tattooed black person they you know they're
known gangbanger like I get I get your apprehension. I get your
willingness to pull the gun immediately anyway. >> Bro,
is the show over? I'm like it's just it's really anxiety producing
man. >> Well, I think both of you would be better off mentally
without doing the show. It's just the financial part that's probably
not great. >> How do you think it's going to go versus
Pisco? It looks like he's amping up to do like the full-blown
like we're both just signaling
arguments. He has he's gotten like a good knowledge. He's looked
up some precedents and stuff. But here's the thing. When you
argue with Pisco, it's going to come down to like he's going
to go, "No, no, no. You don't understand. There's like this piece
of the law. This is how the law works in these cases, and you
just don't understand it." And for me,
I'm the kind of person where I'm like, well, if you tell me this
is how the law works,
I don't have the knowledge to say you're wrong. So, why would
I even engage that conversation? It's like Chud's going to lose
it. Well, I don't think Chud's going to lose the conversation
cuz I don't think I don't think any arcane element of the law
is going to work. I think Chud's going to basically go and I
think this is how it's going to work out in real life is basically
if a cop can even remotely remotely remotely in any minor sense
claim that they're scared for their life is and get mad. Yeah,
you might get mad. If they can claim that they're scared for
their life, they basically could do whatever they want. It's
like actually crazy. Like realistically, I actually think under
the law, Chovin probably should have gotten off. I think under
the law, Chovin probably should have gotten off. I think it was
basically they knew that they that Minnesota would get burned
down to the ground if he got off, right? But unfortunately, sorry,
fortunately, I guess somehow like the crowd went through. Don't
no my one that's not me thinking that Chovin is innocent. Chovin
murdered that guy. I'm telling you that the protections cops
get under the law in the United States are insane. No, sorry.
Sorry. I'm saying under the justice system, I'm saying your legal
system affords police officers the most
protections. I I genuinely think that Chovin might have had some
arguments. Now, I think Chovin can't argue that he's scared for
his life after a certain point in time and that's what gets him.
But that that doesn't exist for this one, right? But I think
Chovin, given he was like scared, he was worried this guy's going
to get aggressive. And there was one other thing. Um, oh, and
that he possibly had in his training manual. I think he almost
got off on that.
>> Um, abolish qualified immunity. I don't know if you
could do that, man. I think I think the reason you can't do that
has to do way more with votes. Okay.
You want to talk about buying votes? You think the Somali community
is buying votes? Wait until you hear about the teachers union
or the police unions. Okay. You think the Somali people in Minnesota
are buying votes? You think they're getting like catered to?
Holy. >> You know, it's giving you anxiety. It's giving
him discomfort, >> some weird ear disease or whatever.
It's >> Well, when he told me when he told me I'm causing
his tonitis, I'm like, well, what? I'm like, how can we do a
show if me talking to you gives you tonitis? >> That's
right. >> Uh, all right, man. Well, you know, I'm not trying
to end the show. I didn't say it the most eloquent way, but basically
my answer was whatever's going on, man. I just I don't want the
show to be about here's another thing Veto did and we're all
mad at Veto and here's Veto's big answer. Like, I that's not
fun. It's really anxiety producing. It makes it hard and it makes
the show worse cuz I come into the show all nervous and anxious
like am I going to get [__] on this week? Like it
[__] up the energy of the show. I'd rather just dude
if you got a problem if you want me to give up if you think I'm
banning people which again this idea I'm banning a [__]
from people is just crazy. But yeah, let's just handle it privately
and we'll figure it out. >> I don't think he wants to figure
it out. >> No, probably not. And that's fine if he doesn't
if he's not enjoying the show. That's also an option. Like tell
me you're not enjoying the show. All right. Thanks, man. Here's
Beach Hook. Beach >> Hi. Hey. >> Hi, Vita.
>> This drama is just rerun after rerun. Well, I think
it seems like Dick shut the show down, but um I don't think he
did. I think Veto doesn't want to shut down and Veto wanted to
give up. So,
let's see here. Veto says right after the style is not happy.
Uh that's funny.
Speaking of nothing, speak of racial profiling. Yeah, there you
go. Boom. So many of the problems are the result of an inability
to communicate effectively with a big spotlight shining in my
face. So, if that results in the end of the podcast, I guess
it's kind of fitting. I don't perform well under pressure. Lol.
What I meant to say was I don't care about having mod privileges.
I just don't want to make a big issue out of it. Send me an email
and tell me what exactly it is you're asking me to do and what
accounts you need me to delete. Sorry I didn't make that intention
clear. Or sorry I didn't make that
Stylo says, "You were totally stance broken by drum roll, bro.
That's more than not performing well under pressure." Okay,
dude. That dude Dick did troll super hard with that drum roll,
though. For real? That drum roll went for like 30 seconds
and Dick literally laughed when Vito was like, "Can you kill
the drum roll?" And Dick like started laughing. He knew he was
being annoying with that. But yeah, he he did kind of get he
did kind of get totally he got totally [__] up by
the drum roll. Kind of rough,
dude. I can't I can't imagine this is actually going to continue
and and they're not going to do the the show anymore. Come on,
man. That can't that can't be possible.